hey there Morgan with ET Canada I'm
obsessed with the whole month thank you
so much with me Emmy's right around the
corner do you have do you have your look
planned out for the night I have a real
look I have a look I'm so excited about
it sort of means like whatever happens
I've got a great dress exactly uh are
you gonna be nervous you're gonna be
excited miss your first Emmy nomination
oh I'm so nervous I'm so excited but I
really I mean it is corny but I do feel
like I've already won I'm so honored and
so blown away just to be nominated so
I'm just gonna go in and enjoy it and
like try and relax
love that uh you know I obviously the
world is still reeling from the news of
the Queen's passing how did you react I
was I'm I'm filming in Rome at the
moment and I felt really sad to be away
from England it's so sad I mean she's
incredible she's left this Legacy that
will last forever and um it's a really
sad time I'm wearing black did you do
that on purpose well yeah I mean I I
think that it's hard isn't it to be to
be sort of so important to celebrate our
film and to be here and of course life
goes on and you know but there is like a
sense of I don't know something somber
about I have to tell you love that
you're honoring the queen like that
that's amazing you're that's awesome all
right let's talk about this wonderful
film the question that I feel like a lot
of people ask these days is it harder to
find love today than it was years ago
well my granny married her my granddad
when she was 19 years old they had the
longer they were married forever until
he passed and she passed just recently
she was similar age to the queen which
is also why with the connection to my
queen I just think of my granny but um
anyway uh and I do think there was a
commitment to that but maybe because
there wasn't so many options you didn't
really have the choice to divorce but I
definitely think we are sometimes
blighted by choice and by options and so
I don't know I it's I think that's what
the film is exploring is this
open-ending question about how to do it
and how to find lasting love and we're
all figuring it out still I think just
wrap things up this is truly for my
producer Jody Mamma Mia 3 anything any
news anything no no no sorry